i am excited on a much smaller scale
of uh mars europa or titan
or venus potentially having very
like bacteria like life forms just on a
on a small human level it's a little bit
scary but mostly really exciting that
there might be life
elsewhere in the volcanoes in the oceans
all around us teaming having little
societies
and whether there's properties about
that kind of life
that's somehow different than ours i
don't know what would be more exciting
if
those colonies of single cell type
organisms
what would be more exciting if they're
different or they're the same
if they're the same that means
through the rest of the universe there's
life forms
like us something like us
everywhere if they're different that's
also really exciting because there's
life forms everywhere they're not like
us
that's a little bit scary i don't know
what's scary actually
i think both scary and exciting no
matter what right
the idea that they could be very
different is philosophically very
interesting for us to open our
aperture on what life and consciousness
and
and self-replicating possibilities could
look like
the question on are they different or
the same obviously there's lots of life
here that is
the same in some ways and different in
other ways
when you take the thing that we call an
invasive species is something that's
still
pretty the same hydrocarbon based thing
but co-evolved
with co-selective pressures in a certain
environment we move it to another
environment it might be devastating to
that whole
ecosystem because it's just different
enough that it messes up the
self-stabilizing dynamics of that
ecosystem so
the question of are they
would they be different in ways where we
could still
figure out a way to inhabit a biosphere
together
or fundamentally not fundamentally the
nature of how they operate in the nature
of how we operate would be
incommensurable is a deep question well
we offline talked about
memetic theory right it seems like
if there were sufficiently different
where we
would not even we can coexist on
different planes
uh it seems like a a good thing if we're
close enough
together to where we'd be competing then
it's you're getting into the world of
viruses and pathogens and all those
kinds of things
to where we would uh one of us would die
off quickly through basically mass
murder
without even even accidentally even
accidentally
if we just had a self-replicating
single-celled kind of creature
that happened to
not work well for the hydrocarbon life
that was here that got introduced
because
it either output something that was
toxic or utilized up the same resource
too quickly and it just replicated
faster and mutated faster
it wouldn't be a um memetic theory
conflict theory kind of harm it would
just be
a von neumann machine a self-replicating
machine that was
fundamentally incompatible with these
kinds of self-replicating systems
with faster ooda loops
you